Absolut, nämen så är det säkert.
If a random person goes up to a bunch of 15-16 year olds and says, I called my colleagues, we're going to start a podcast now.
Solved it, we're starting to record on Monday.
I'm going to call Aftonbladet later and find out a name for her on the podcast.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt, det kör vi på.
Då går vi vidare.
Välkommen till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Idag sitter vi med den fantastiska gnestaprofilen Joakim Vång.
Ja just det, hej.
Ja, du var blygsamt.
Ja, det är nog lite typiskt mig kanske.
Idag sitter vi också, vi ska säga att vi sitter lite på en arbetsplats idag, så om det låter lite med skruvmejselar och muttrar och sånt i bakgrunden så kommer förklaringen till det lite senare.
Ni ser ju inte Joakim nu men han ser aningen blyg ut.
Och jag har fått reda på inför detta att han är lite obekväm med att spela in podd men vi ska försöka få honom att slappna av och känna sig bekväm.
Jag har sagt att jag varsamt ska leda honom genom den här poddintervjun till lyssnarnas glädje.
Kan du inte dra en liten kort intro om vem du är och varför du är här?
Jo, 40 år.
Jag skötte, upplyttad till Gnesta.
Jag har bott här i 12-13 år tror jag.
Och så för 6 år sedan så startade jag ett gym.
Och du har varit med från start där.
Av mig skit vi, men du startade ett gym?
Mm.
Och gymmet heter?
Styrkfabriken.
Och det har blivit lite som navet här i Gnesta.
Nu har vi ju varit och käkat lunch här två dagar.
Och det är inte ofta man går längs med gatan och det är inte tre personer som kommer fram och hälsar.
Är det så det brukar se ut?
Det blir mycket gymsnack det blir det.
Så är det nog.
Jag har inte tänkt på det så mycket.
Nu först vi pratar om det.
Men det är nog ganska mycket vardag att det blir så.
Skulle du säga att du är rätt trött på att prata gym?
Eller kan du fortfarande bry dig om vad folk knäböjer?
Nej men jag trottar nog inte på det faktiskt.
Den där vardagen så att jag tycker det är ganska intressant.
Och fortfarande roligt och jag är fortfarande också jobbar som PT och så där för att det blir ganska mycket att snacka om träning och hur man kan hjälpa och hur man ska komma vidare och allting med träning egentligen.
Ja för du är lite, du är ju stark själv.
Du har ju lite halvkarriär inom styrkesporten.
Ja vissa saker har ju gått lite lättare.
Bengtpressen bra, markligt lite sämre.
Ja men du är ju duktig på Bengtpress kan du inte ge oss lite background.
Alltså skit i hela den här ödmjukhetgrejen, den skiter folk i.
Vi vill höra vad, för du har tävlat i Bengtpress på riktigt liksom.
Ja och jag ska faktiskt åka till VM Texas nu vid maj.
Så ja, så den blir rolig.
Jo men Bengt har alltid funkat ganska så bra för mig.
För tio år sedan började jag tävla.
Och sen så har det väl, det har blivit en del SM, guld och lite IEM-medaljer och så där.
Och sen nu är det VM då.
Så där har det väl gått.
Vad är största vinsten?
Vad är den du är stolt över?
Egentligen är det nog mitt första SM-guld tror jag.
Det var?
2017 kanske.
Det var en väldigt bra tävling och jag kom från ingenstans egentligen.
Och kunde överraska ganska mycket.
Så den kommer jag alltid ihåg.
Sen så har man varit lite bortskämd kanske med tävlingar och så där, men jag kommer ihåg just den första.
Sen jag två på IEM förra året, den var väl ganska bra.
Den tar du med eftertanke.
Den var hygglig liksom.
Ja den känns väldigt bra.
Vad var det som gjorde att du började tävla i bänkpress?
För du tävla med tröja vilket ju är ganska...
Ja började med klassiskt och så var det Norrfarnstad och Tälje som täda.
Och så tyckte de att det var nog potential.
Vill du komma hit och köra lite och de körde med tröja.
Och jag hade varit på två SM klassiskt och kommit fyra.
Så jag kände mig såhär, ja, tröja, kan vi ju prova.
Och så hade jag väl ganska så bra vinklar, det gick bra från början med tröja.
Och det är ju annars en materialsport som är ganska så svår att behärska.
Så det kom väl ganska så naturligt för mig som tur var.
Så då började jag träna där och så började jag med på mitt första SM och tog 245 och vann ganska överlagsätt i den.
Och så på den resan, den vägen fortsatte bara.
Ja, och hur länge kan man, nu menar jag detta med den mesta av kärlek men du är ju inte pur ung, du är ju inte en 25-åring liksom.
Hur länge tävlar man på högstad?
Du ska ändå på VM liksom.
Jag lever på någon sån här, någon sa, nu vet inte om det är sant, men någon sa när jag började såhär, nej men i styrkuliv så kan man hålla på, du som stärker är runt 40.
Okej.
Tveksamt om det kanske stämmer men jag har det bakom mig.
Du lever i den illusionen, exakt ja.
Nej men jag kan snart pika.
Nej men rent tränningsmässigt så tränar jag ganska så mycket lugnare.
Jag stressar inte upp om jag missar ett pass.
Jag har missat väldigt många pass nu för tiden egentligen, men man har lärt sig att fokusera och inte stressa upp sig och vara skadefri.
Jag tror det är egentligen det som är.
Jag har varit skadefri väldigt länge.
Ja.
Det är fan så rörligt.
Det är jättebra, men då vet vi lite grann vem du är.
Du är stark i bänkpress och du driver ett gym och du hänger i gnästa.
Ungefär så, en sammanfattning.
Och vi ska ju prata lite grann.
Mitt mål med det här avsnittet är ju att vi ska belysa lite hur man startar ett gym, hur man kommer igång med det och framförallt hur man faktiskt kan leva på det.
För det finns ju rätt många gymägare därute som har ett gym, men de tar aldrig ut en lön.
Och tar de ut en lön så är det ingen riktig lön.
Och det blir liksom ingenting riktigt av, utan det är mycket så här passionsprojekt.
Och det är lite tråkigt.
Så jag tänkte att vi ska prata om det.
Men du har styrkefabriken.
Hur stor är den?
Vad omsätter den?
Vad fokuserar ni på?
Vad gör ni där?
Från början så var det ju bara tänkt att vara en rolig grej vid sidan om.
Det gick det ju med att jag tränade på.
Jag hade mina tankar och åsikter om hur man kunde göra det ännu bättre.
Men jag tyckte väl inte att man fick det gehöret.
Så satt vi och kollade på lokal.
Och så hittade vi en lokal.
Så tänkte jag, jag har ingen aning om hur det går till att starta gym och så där.
Så vi tog kontakt och fick komma och titta på lokalen.
Den var bra, tanken började växa fram mer och mer att det skulle vara häftigt.
Sen att det skulle vara lönsamt var heller inte tanken utan det var mer...
Det är skönt om man har ett eget ställe att träna på.
Men att lokalen vi hittade, de var ju ganska så stor.
Och så började jag ju tänka runt.
När du säger ganska så stor, hur stor är det?
360 kvadrat.
Det är stort att ha som garagegym.
Ja, men så tänkte vi och satt och räknade lite på.
Ja men, jag har ju några vänner.
De kan säkert komma och träna.
Om man delar upp det, hyr en hyra, ja men det kan bli dyrt, men det kan vara skönt.
Och ja, vi kanske kommer in någon mer.
Lite så var det i början.
Och sen så fick man ju komma på att man måste starta en aktiebolag.
Och logga och inpasseringssystem.
Allt det där, det blir väldigt, för jag tror att vi kollar på lokalen i mars.
I april tror jag vi hade fixat det här bolaget.
Och signat alla kontrakt där i april.
Och sen så startade vi i augusti.
Men när du signade kontraktet, då hade du ingen koll på inpasseringssystemen.
Nej och ärligt att man såg på, så kollar jag även fastighetsägaren och så snackade man sen efterhand att jag trodde nog aldrig på det här egentligen eller.
Men samtidigt så trodde han på det så pass mycket att han vågade ändå signera upp oss.
Han tänkte att han kunde få in en halvhyra där i någon månad i alla fall.
Han hade stått tom där ett tag och han tänkte ja men det finns ju mycket i gymnasiet redan.
Så att det kan ju vara svårt.
Men jag trodde på idén, ju mer man planerade och tänkte och hur var är alla de yngre personerna?
Var är alla?
Så här jämfört med grannkommuner till exempel så så tycker jag att det var märkligt att till exempel tjejer bara tränar tonårskillar.
Det kan ju inte vara så att de som gymmer bara redan gymmar för så många jämfört med andra kommuner så att jag började tänka mig att det kanske finns någonting här.
Så från början var det lite av en det här är någonstans där jag vill träna på mitt sätt och sen med tiden blev det lite, ja men det här kan vi kommersialisera.
Ja.
Eller blev du tvingad och kommersialiserade för att gå runt?
Nej, det som hände var väl att vi märkte, eller jag märkte att det fanns en otrolig efterfrågan.
Att det var så som man hade börjat fundera på och att det var ju på öppningsdagen så var det över tusen personer den helgen som var och besökte oss.
Det är sjukt.
Jag tror att Gnesta har fem och ett halvtusen invånare.
Ja, hela kommunen har väl runt 11 tror jag.
Det är lite som att du öppnar ett gym i Stockholm som skulle ha 200 000 personer på oss.
Ja, det räknar på breakeven där och så där.
Jag tror det tog en eller två veckor, sen var det lugnt.
Det är ganska bra jobbat.
Ja, så man behövde inte ha den.
Men jag hade mer räknat på att jag kanske fått ha lite lån här igen och se om man kan täcka hyror ett halvår.
Få se att någon gång borde det kanske.
När började du jobba i bolaget?
Alltså heltid, för du jobbade med ett vanligt jobb innan.
Jag är behandlingspedagog.
Så jag har jobbat missbruk, mycket psyksohälsa, mycket diagnoser och sådär.
På den tiden så jobbade jag i en skola, gjorde jag, som elevassistent.
För jag behövde ha ett dagtidsjobb.
Så jag hade ju aldrig, jag gick i företagsekonomi.
Det var den närmsta företagen i sådana här.
Det är bättre än vad jag har gjort.
Vem bryr sig?
Så när man hade bra kontakter också sådär, runtomkring som de drev företag så kunde de i alla fall berätta fördelar med ett aktiebolag, eller vad en enskild firma är och sådär.
Nu kommer jag inte ihåg frågan här.
Nej du, jag har ingen aning, men det spelar ingen roll sen.
Allting blev ju mycket större med alla investeringarna som blev också.
Så att jag har ingen aning om vad vi pratar om.
Nej jag frågade när du började jobba heltid med detta.
Ja, jag jobbade ju dygnet runt, kan man ju säga.
Samtidigt som jag hade mitt heltidsjobb i skolan.
Sen blev det mycket på gymmet och jag kunde gå ner mer och mer i tid.
Jag hade svårt att hinna med, men man jobbade ju dygnet runt.
Man nåbar i den tiden.
Efter två och ett halvt år, när pandemin kom, då hade jag tagit känslighet från jobbet och sagt nu satsar jag på det här och då kom pandemin.
Det var lite körigt där ett tag.
Men ni körde positivt resultat genom hela pandemin också?
Ja, det gjorde vi.
Det var ganska imponerande.
Det kan ju bara tacka egentligen våra yngre medlemmar.
Ungdomarna körde ju på.
Innebandy, hockey, fotboll, det stängde ju ner.
Men föräldrarna behövde rösta sina barn någonstans så det var de som höll igång hela verksamheten kan man säga.
Vad omsatte ni nu det senaste boksluttsåret?
Ja det var runt tre, tre och en halv tror jag.
Är det därifrån ni har legat de senaste åren eller har ni någon?
Vi har väl haft en ökning mellan 10 till 20 procent varje år.
Så i början där så kunde man ju tack vare att det inte tog ut någon lön och så att återinvistera allting hela tiden.
Ja för du har ju byggt ut lokalen ett par gånger.
Ja precis, för idag är det 850 kvadrat.
Så där, lokalen var ju otroligt bra.
För att vi hade ju tur där.
För Veggie Veggs lån dagde verksamhet som helt plötsligt valde att nej men vi ska ta våra verksamheter och flytta till Flen eller någonstans.
Så då dök det upp en 200-300 kvadrat.
Så då tog vi den.
Och då kom jag och sa, ja, då trodde ju Fassisägarna.
Han hade börjat lita på det efter några år, ja.
Ja, för då var det, det var i ett kontorsamskap jättefint.
Men så rensade de allting och byggde upp allting på nytt där inne och så sa jag såhär, det finns ju en källare där nere.
Där vi egentligen hade velat från början, för det är sex meter tak och det är ett speciellt miljö.
Men spara en liten korridor här, ifall.
Och så kommer vi att skratta lite åt det här för att det skulle bara vara i fantasin, att det skulle kunna gå.
Men sedan, vad var det, två år senare, så sa vi nu kan vi ta en källare.
Ja och det var under pandemin faktiskt, innan den hade liksom klingat av sådär.
Men då kände vi att nu kommer säkert folk att komma tillbaka och nu kör vi.
Så då kunde vi ta ytterligare 250 kvadrat, så nu har vi 850.
Är det tjockt där nu, går det att bygga ut ännu mer?
Det går att bygga ut, det finns ungefär en 200 kvadrat kvar, som jag går och planera för.
Okej, jag förstår.
Vi får se, nästa år kanske då har det utvecklat ännu mer.
Vad var det knepigaste med den här uppstarten?
Knepigaste var väl egentligen att jag inte kunde någonting.
Och när du säger kunde inte någonting, var det att du inte kunde någonting om att driva gym, eller var det att du inte kunde någonting om att driva bolag?
För det är lite olika saker.
Jag kunde nog ingenting om att driva bolag eller om gym egentligen.
Mer än att jag hade tränat på gym.
Och jag är nog så som person att om jag är på en arbetsplats, så tycker jag att jag hittar hela tiden förbättringsmöjligheter.
Så jag visste ju när jag började föräldrar, vad jag tyckte så här borde det vara.
Som tur var så hade ju människor runt omkring mig som kunde berätta lite.
Om, jag hade kontakt med ett annat gym, men vi använde de här som inpasseringssystem.
Och så kunde man liksom snacka med dem, och sen så fick man tag på någon som kunde göra en logga, och hemsida, eller ja, jag gjorde hemsidan.
Jag ska inte göra hemsidan.
Så jag blev totalt nedringd av sådana här webdesigner och sa, du behöver hjälp, jag vet.
Men, och sen.
Ja.
Men ja, men det funkade.
Men okej, så det var själva bakgrundsarbetet lite grann.
För du sa ju att ni fick ganska bra kundrulljans redan från start.
Vad tror du gjorde att ni fick?
Var det bara att det fanns ett uppnämnd behov eller var det någonting?
Ja, tanken var ju mycket såhär att...
För det måste ju ändå vara det svåraste för gym, förutom såklart att dra igång gymmet, men sen att faktiskt få in en kundbas som gör att du kan rulla på det.
Ja, där försökte man ju tänka till med färgen på loggen.
Hur var det för namn och färgerna i lokalen och allting?
För att vi ville väl locka alla.
Och speciellt då, vi visste inte egentligen var tjejer tränade i Gnesta.
För jag tränade på ett gym, men där var ju bara killar.
Kom det in en tjej, det var ju konstigt nästan.
Jaha, var det så i Gnesta?
På det här gymmet.
Så visste man att det fanns något gym som hade lite, ja de hade kvinnor men var lite äldre eller kanske körde lite spinning och sådär.
Ni försökte skapa ett lite mer inkluderande gym där alla kände sig lite hemma.
Ja och sen så liten här tanken, kommer tjejerna så kommer killarna.
Okej, det är så, okej ja.
Nej men så var först och främst.
Nej det kan inte funka så jag har inte.
Men först och främst gör det en otroligt trevlig miljö.
Och ni hade ju redan från start väl lite barnpassning.
Ja barnrum.
Ja, och det var ju, ni har ju en liten yta där man kan sitta och äta och hela den här.
Och jag har ju varit där och byggt gymutrustning i olika omgångar.
Det sitter ju folk där och bara köta liksom som sitter där rätt länge.
Ja vissa kommer ju alldeles in på gymmet.
De kan hänga där ett par timmar liksom och bara sitta där.
Ja, mycket så.
Så att, och idag så är det väl, finns det egentligen ingen målgrupp som saknas heller?
Vi har väl i alla åldrarna och...
Men kan inte det vara en nackdel då att om man inte specialiserar sig så blir det ju också lite ett bärst gym.
Förstår du vad jag menar då?
Ser du någon fara där?
Ja, dels så att det är jättetredligt.
Stämningen blir ju väldigt bra när det är lite mindre.
Dels är det för att någon grann, någon mormor är där.
Det blir en fin stämning.
Men när 20-16-åriga killar som går runt i klungor för de tränar, unga killar vill ofta komma och träna lite i grupp i början.
Jag gjorde samma sak.
Ja, för man är lite osäker och det blir lite stökigt.
Även om det inte stökar så kan det upplevas lite stökigt.
Och sen så kommer någon annan in som är efter jobbet, som en kvinna på 50 år.
Då tycker inte hon ofta att det här var jättekul.
Att alla ungdomar är här.
Det var ju trevligt.
Hur jobbar man med det då för att det ska kännas bekvämt?
Jag har ju jobbat mycket med ungdomar innan.
Det är det jag har gjort egentligen så att man snackar ju med dem.
Jag tycker att de är kanonfina och de ungdomar som finns, de lyssnar.
Men sen är det ju bara det att de finns.
Så tror jag skapar en känsla för många äldre.
Om vi läser mellan raderna då så är du duktig på att säga åt folk att skärpa sig.
Du är ju en ganska bred person.
Kan det vara så att du är bekväm med att säga åt folk och tysta ner sig lite?
Jag har inte tänkt så.
Jag har bara tänkt att de bara lyssnar på mig.
Absolut, så är det säkert.
Om en random människa går fram till ett gäng, 15 stycken 16-åringar säger, kan ni inte ta det lite lugnt här för biatatränar, då brukar de alltid på vanliga gym bara sätta sig ner och ta det lite lugnt.
Har du aldrig reflekterat över det här?
Jo men, tanken visst, men jag tänker väl ändå att det är väldigt uppostrade ungdomar som liksom lyssnar på äldre.
Det är klart, det är bara väldigt uppostrade ungdomar på gym.
Det är klart det är så.
Fan, det är ingen självinsikt på det här stället.
Yes.
En jättestor diskussion inom gymvärlden har varit det här med hur man ska prissätta och hur man ska, och eftersom du ändå har gått med lönsamhet hela tiden, har du tänkt på prissättning eller har du bara satt ett pris som det här känns rimligt?
Lite så var det från början.
Det senaste?
Ja, vi höftade väl till någonstans där.
Men sen fanns det faktiskt en idé om att man måste hålla lite högre pris än de andra gymmen, utifrån att det håller mycket betydligt högre kvalitet.
Och sen så var det den här saken som jag kommer ihåg, det var ett löpande som gick sönder.
Då kunde man beställa ett samma dag och ha pengarna till det.
Och så stod ett nytt löpande inom, faktiskt då, den gången inom 36 timmar, så kom det upp andra och så kunde man ställa det dit.
Och då tänker jag att den servicen kommer folk att se.
Och sen så att vi återinvesterade allting i början, så för att kunna bygga det som finns idag.
Så tror jag många människor såg också att pengarna inte försvann bara till någonting.
Det kom nya saker.
Men det här med prisen, det är lite, det är ju klurigt det här.
Vad är det som är klurigt?
Är det att det tar emot att sätta ett visst pris, eller är det mer att man är osäker på om man kan sätta ett visst pris?
Och hur tänker man med studenter kontra vuxna?
Hur har din filosofi liva?
Ja student, helt plötsligt studerar ju alla.
Och sen har man glömt sitt messenatkort och sådär.
Sen är det ju så här när man någonstans, vad man ska säga, inte dålig affärsmann eller så, men någonstans vill man ju att alla ska ha råd och träna.
Samtidigt som man vill hålla en hög standard.
Och lägger man sig för lågt också, man vill ju någonstans att om man betalar för någonting så är man rädd om det.
Så det där är en balansgång också.
För att man vill inte vara för dyr heller.
Samtidigt som att man vill vara dyrare än de andra på ett sätt.
Jag förstår.
Men jag tror att det är relativt ovanligt ändå.
Att när man går in som ny aktör, att man ändå har modet att tänka att jag gör en produkt här lite bättre, så jag vågar sätta i alla fall ett pris som är några kronor dyrare, så jag kan göra en lite bättre produkt.
Det är ganska många av de här nya gymmen med, alltså fristående gym, där folk sätter ett pris som kanske sätter sig på 2,99, med ett annat Nordic Wellness som bara är öppet över natten.
Så har man ingen möjlighet att leva på det, för det går liksom inte.
Nej, och det där har jag tänkt på att har man liksom en verksamhetsen tidigare om man har råd att gå bak några miljoner första året.
Jag vet ett gym som hade årskort för tusen kronor.
Så här, och det är klart att de fick mycket medlemmar.
Men det går liksom inte, du måste göra något otroligt mycket medlemmar för att få kunna gå och gå runt.
Så jag har ju svårt att se hur andra gym egentligen kan gå runt.
Jag får inte ditt ihop ekvationer här faktiskt.
Ja, men jag förstår.
Har du någon känsla för vad det är du gör bra ändå?
Eftersom gymmet går runt och du lever på detta.
Jag tror en sak var väl att man började lära sig att lyssna på andra medlemmar, alltså kunder, vad efterfrågan är.
Jag visste ju inte någonting om Crossfit.
Jag kom in från miljöet och tänkte såhär, ja men vi ska träna, vi träna med skivstänger och vi gör det här och vi ska inte ha några kettebell eller sådana bollar eller sådana här inåt utrotterande benmaskin.
Men det var ju bara ganska vika sig ganska så fort och lära sig vad allmänheten vill ha, inte bara vad jag vill ha.
Vissa saker strider jag fortfarande lite motståndare till som en vadpress sådär, säger jag, försöker.
Men trappmaskinnen kom.
Är det vadpressen som är din största fight?
Eller har du haft någon annan fight som har varit såhär, det här har jag hållit emot.
Det flockas kring Kabycrossen.
Och jag försöker få dem att säga, men det finns så många andra övningar.
Men nej.
Men lockar du spegeln kanske?
Det kanske kan lösa i allting med flera speglar, nu när jag tänker efter.
Är det de här 16-åriga pojkarna som flockas?
Nej, alla.
Ja, alla flockas där?
Ja.
Och även om man har tränat väldigt länge, men du har ju tränat i 20 år, du vet att du kan träna basis på andra sätt.
Men jag vet inte om det är...
Du vill inte köpa in fler Kabycross där men...
Det känns så hos mig.
Ja, jag förstår.
Vad tror du det största misstaget folk gör när de startar ett gym?
Man kanske inte förstår hur mycket jobb det ligger bakom, allting för att få det att rulla.
Jag hade en kompis som ringde och frågade, bara jag trodde om ett gym som man kunde köpa och sa ja och så där, men han är inte så händig.
Så frågade jag hur tänkte du med det här?
Nej men det får någon annan göra då.
Okej, men jag sa att jag inte har haft semester, eller jag har jobbat nåbar dygnet runt i 6,5 år.
Jag trivs bra med det, det har inte gjort mig någonting.
Men han, då bara tvärnigt, han sa nej men då vill jag inte ha.
Många kanske har en föreställning om det, och det hade jag också i början, för jag tror att jag drar igång gymmet.
Sen så kanske jag är där någon gång i veckan, tittar till det lite, byter en sopsäck och sen flyter det allting på.
Och riktigt så har det ju inte varit.
Nej.
Det är ju så här, och i förrgåringen ringde någon kille 11 på kvällen och frågade sig någonting om gymmet.
Men då sa jag faktiskt att du vet att klockan är 11.
Vad svarar han då då?
Jo, just det.
Då bad han om ursäkt och så ringde han nästa dag istället.
Ja, det var ändå rimligt.
Men har du ditt nummer på hemsidan så får jag ringa.
Ja, det kanske också är en grej.
Lite får du skylla dig själv om du har telefonen på 11.
Ja, och den köper jag för det är mitt egna.
Att jag har valt att ha den så.
Och svarar jag så svarar jag, och då börjar jag ju skylla mig själv.
Men ibland blir man ju nyfiken.
Men fan ingen mer.
Vad kan vara så viktigt?
Brinner det typ?
Ja, jag förstår.
Jag har ju ståkat dig lite grann här i några år.
Jag var ju med när du startade det andra gymmet och fick leverera dit då.
Så då var vi uppe och byggde.
Det var du och så var det ju Robin, min kollega var ju med och byggde och så var det ju ett antal stora herrar.
Det var väl din gamla bänkpressgrupp kan jag tänka mig.
Ja, det var några där.
Jag minns bara att jag kände mig som en liten dvärg när vi var där och byggde.
Och jag har ju alltid tyckt om hur du driver gym.
Jag tycker du har en väldigt avspända approach till det samtidigt som du jobbar hårt.
Så jag har ju försökt köpa in mig i ditt gym under lång tid kan man ju säga.
Jag vet inte hur många gånger jag har frågat genom åren.
Det måste vara åtta i alla fall.
Ja, ganska regelbundet.
Är det inte dags nu liksom?
Och du har ju nekat mig genom åren och det gör ju bara mig ännu mer het på gröten.
För det känns ju som, nu har jag ju flickvän och barn så detta blir ju min tjejs.
Om du förstår vad jag menar.
Det blir ju nästan som när man jagade flickor.
Men nu har ju vi ett nytt projekt igång.
För någonstans här på vägen för något halvår sen, år sen, så liksom gav du efter.
Ja.
Så vad är det vi ska göra nu?
Nu så...
Startar vi ju...
Utan att det ska låta sensuellt liksom.
Ja, nu startar vi ett gym ihop.
Ja.
Styrkekompanier.
I samma stad.
Ja.
Men det är på andra sidan gnest.
Och gnest är ju väldigt stort.
Men man ska inte underskatta 10 minuter alltså.
Eller, alltså så långt emellan det här är inte 10 minuter men...
Ja, tre minuter liksom.
Ja, kanske.
Långsam promenad.
Ja.
Nej men, jag märkte väl på gymmet, på fabriken där, att det blev ju...
Det är mycket människor och jag trivdes inte riktigt med det för då började det bli såhär, nej det är så mycket folk eller det blir stökigt och så vidare.
Och jag har ju alltid velat gjort någonting mer.
Så då det är ju det här och så dök en lokal upp.
Och ja, sen gick det ganska fort.
Egentligen.
Ja, jag hade ju skrivit ett avtal färdigt liksom sedan sju år tillbaka.
Jag satt ju bara och väntade på play.
Fan jag hade en sådan fond undanlagd bara för det här så att.
Ja men det gick, ja vi hade väl ett möte och sen så sa man, men då skakar vi hand när vi fikar bål och så, då kör vi.
Ja, ja det är väl rimligt.
Vad skulle du säga att du gör, för nu öppnar ju detta gymmet om tio dagar ungefär, när vi spelar in detta.
Så när detta släpps så har det ju precis öppnat antagligen.
Vad gör du annorlunda i det här gymmet jämfört med öppningen i förra gymmet?
Det här gymmet vet jag ju att, ja, annorlunda.
Dels så kommer jag ju in med ganska mycket mer kunskap om, man använder alla sina gamla kontakter och leverantörer och allting, så att, och den här gången vet man också att man måste söka bygdlåg.
Det visste jag inte förra.
Ja, det här blev en jätteintressant upplevelse att vänta på sju år sedan.
Och du har byggt en fantastisk hemsida den här gången.
Ja.
Allting.
Folk kan väl gå in och kolla på styrkikompaniet.se.
För jag gissar att den kommer se ut som den gör nu.
Du har lagt ner all din kompetens i den hemsidan.
Jag ska bygga.
Den kan vi göra mycket mer avancerad, men då kommer det kosta oss lite mer.
Det är en standard.
Va?
Är det en standardmall?
Jag kämpade med den, det gjorde jag.
En väldigt avancerad Facebook och Instagram har jag också.
Ja, oja.
Det är bara...
Det är grafiskt grej.
Nej, det är någonting med mig och färger och form, det funkar liksom inte.
Ja, det är märkligt.
Jag vet inte, det är något.
Nej, jag förstår.
Det är skönt, vi är två stycken sådana, för när du har såhär bett om åsikter och logga och sånt så...
Nej, tar du det?
Eller du får ha alla åsikter.
Jag är nog ännu sämre på det.
Men det jag vet är att det var faktiskt du som sa till mig för många åren.
Jag gör bara det jag kan och det jag inte kan, det är för dem som kan göra det.
Ganska rimligt i och för sig.
Men den har jag tänkt på nu så att när det kom till loggan, det var inte så att jag satte mig ner ens försök.
Det där var ju bara...
Ja, outsourcade.
Non smart.
Jag förstår.
Men återigen då, vad gör du annorlunda i detta?
Kan du ge några praktiska exempel som du gjorde rätt denna gången, som du gjorde fel denna gången, som man kan lära sig av?
Bygglov, sade du till exempel?
Ja.
Den processen är bra och drar igång direkt.
Jag kommer så väl ihåg den.
När jag satt där på kajen och lärde...
Nu ser ni inte Joakim, men han ser verkligen förstörd ut när han tittar ner igång.
Det var en sommarlag och så ringer telefonen och det var ju trevligt och så bara hej, du måste ha bygglov.
Ja.
Vad är det man måste ha bygglov för?
Förändring av verksamhet.
Okej, okej.
Och då sa jag nej, varför?
Det är inget sagt.
Och det behövdes.
Men där fick det ordna sig.
Allting ordnade sig väldigt bra och kommunen hjälpte till massavista.
Men det är här när man satt ett datum och gått ut med det offentligt att 12 augusti, då kör vi.
Men någonstans, för att jag inte kunde så mycket, så blev jag inte alltid stressad heller för när de sa bygglov, ja men...
Det tar väl en kvart.
Ja, här var det du ville veta.
Nu kör vi.
Så att det var lite stressigt, men det gick ju.
Och det var ju samma här nu.
Det är det som har gjort att det har tagit lite mer tid just för de sakerna.
Men det ordnade sig.
Okej, så bygglov är en av de stora grejerna.
Finns det någon mer grej som gör annorlunda?
Som har gjorts smidigare denna gången.
Du behöver inte komma på någonting.
Alltså jag tyckte jag gjorde det ganska så bra när det är första gången.
Ja men då sa du.
Då gjorde du det bra den gången.
Så lös bygglov gott folk.
Det är den stora.
Ja, nu kan jag vara där.
Ja, nej jag förstår.
Detta blir ju två gym på samma ort.
Kan du säga vad som är en fördel och en nackdel med det?
Det finns ju många som kanske har ett gym på en ort och som också har funderat på det någon gång.
Ja i min värld så var det ju så här att Gnesta är lite underskattat när det kommer till.
Eller alltså man skämtar om att man ska ha lika många gym som pizzerier för det finns så mycket gym här och det finns mycket pizzerier.
Jag tänker ju att när jag jämför Gnesta kommun mot andra kommuner som är liknande så så har man helt så har man andra gymm, större gym.
Här har vi gym som kanske rent lokal.
Den lokalen de sitter i inte har kunnat utvecklas så mycket och man kanske har också stannat i, man har nog varit väldigt bekväm tror jag i hur gym är.
Ja det är väl ganska vanligt på mindre orter kanske att man har haft ett gym som har eller jag kommer ju själv från landet och de gymmen har ju funnits där i all evighet och så ofta blir det så, man vänner ju sig vid det.
Nu glömde jag bort en gång att vi pråkat för att...
Vad är fördelen med två gymmen är?
Ja fördelen med två gymmen är att nu vet ju jag vad som behöver liksom, vilket efterfrågan som finns på fabriken.
Vi har, jag vet inte hur stor andel vi har egentligen men men vi har nog det största gymmet i alla fall.
Och då kunde jag se att dels på den här sidan av Gnästa, visst att det som sagt, Gnästa är litet men det är något visst med avstånd.
Ja, jag förstår absolut.
Man är ju lat som människa.
Och där på styrkfabriken, där har vi pass.
Och vi har stora öppna ytor och så där och så.
Där man skulle kunna få utföra, nu kallar vi ju inte det för crossfit.
För det är inte det man gör.
Vi gör bara väldigt liknande moment där.
Och här så kommer man inte att ha några pass.
Här blir det mycket mer, som ett väldigt, väldigt bra nyckelgym, om man säger så.
Det är ju mycket fria vikter här.
Det blir ju, du har ju tre combo racks, det är ju inte jättemånga, alltså riktiga anläggningar som har det.
Och sen lägger du in några power racks på det.
Och så har du ju några goda friviksmaskiner och rejäla hantlar.
Alltså det är ju...
Och sen att vi har miljön här har vi gjort lite roare, lite tuffare om man säger.
Men sen också att det finns möjlighet att kunna växa även i den här lokalen.
Det tror jag att när man letar lokal att verkligen se över, för då hamnar du och bygger upp en hel verksamhet i en för liten lokal, så kommer det troligtvis snabbt växa ur den.
Ja och gym blir ju lätt lite...
Jag har ju försökt neka dig i vissa köp ibland, för att jag kan ju tycka att det blir lite trångt ibland.
Kan vara skönt att ha det lite luftigt.
Ja, jag hör vad du säger.
Du håller inte med, men du hör vad jag säger.
Det var ju det första du sa här.
Nu kan man ju för lyssnarnas skull säga att jag och Joakim går in i detta och blir delägare i båda två i gymmet.
Och jag tänker ju någonstans, det är klart man inte får tillbaka pengarna på detta på några år, men någonstans kanske man får tillbaka pengarna på det.
Men din första mening när vi börjar ställa upp maskiner här är ju, fan jag kan få in några maskiner till där.
Här skulle vi kunna, för jag inser att det kommer att ta, att allt kapital här kommer återinvesteras under lång tid framöver.
Så är det ju.
Jag har ju inga illusioner om vad som händer i det här jävla gymmet.
Yes.
Jag bär smygsjöpa saker från någon annan, eller?
I något annat namn också.
Jag tänkte att vi ska avsluta med frågan, har du några tips till den som ska starta ett gym?
Ja, jag har tänkt på den där, den saken och egentligen, man kan ju säga massa saker som, se till att du har en bra affärsplan, se till att du, men allt mycket kokar ner till egentligen att se till att du gör det med bra personer.
Det är egentligen det viktigaste att förstå själva också att man måste jobba väldigt hårt, och att du kommer träffa på, och du måste kunna ta väldigt många människor.
Men att, vilka du har, vilka instruktörer du har, eller vilka som hjälper dig med någonting, det är egentligen det allra viktigaste.
Men tror du att du kan driva ett gym som en halv, jag är ju inte till exempel en särskilt social människa.
Jag gillar ju att vara tyst, men du är ju en extremt social människa.
Kan man driva, och du behöver inte säga såhär nej, för att jag ser ju hur du köttar med varenda människa.
Och ni pratar gymkort, du är ju säljare av rang.
Det är ju inte min sort, liksom.
Kan man driva ett gym och få det att gå runt, om man inte är den sorten säljare i grunden?
Jag tror den är svår.
För jag tror ändå att den här närvaro, den stora närvaron jag försöker ha, ofta vara tillgänglig, är det någon som ber mig om någonting, så fixar jag det.
Det ska vara enkelt och aldrig försöka liksom, vara girig eller omöjlig.
Och jag kan faktiskt inte förstå riktigt företagare, som inte förstår den här saken, är det otredet mot någon, så kommer ju den ha en kompis, de har en kompis, de har en...
Så stort är inte Sverige, det kommer liksom att höras.
Så det slår mig alltid när man själv pratar med någon, som får man lite bryt så att, den försöker jag verkligen tänka på.
Hur man är som vid möten.
Det har sedan också, det som jag tycker har varit roligt, det är så att jag tycker det är roligt också, att man har kunnat, också för någonting som jag har velat, att kunna stötta vissa, som föreningar, itas föreningar, och det ger ju absolut tillbaks väldigt mycket.
Ja det måste ju vara ett ganska bra tips, jag tror att många smågym missar att föreningar och idrottsklubbar, att göra samarbeten med dem.
Du gör ju en del sådana och då, är klart att de får kanske billigare priser här och där när de kör i bulk, men du får ju in en stabil kundbas.
Det här är ju något man inte vill avslöja i riktigt, men jo men så är det för att, och där har jag aldrig riktigt förstått hur man ska kunna tänka att man ska tjäna massa pengar på föreningarna, om de vill träna lite.
Som här om fotbollslaget kommer kan vi få köra några pass.
Det är bara att komma och göra det.
Börja inte säga då vill jag ha fyra för det här.
Så jag och samarbetarna med alla föreningar som jag är igna i det här.
Sen hur mycket man håller igång, det är mycket upp till föreningarna också.
Men där är ju alltid öppen.
Och det är så här också när vi kommer att gå in i samarbete, direkt när vi har flera föreningar.
Vi kan klippa dig.
Haha, yes.
Joakim, det är en glädje att ha haft med dig i podden.
Jag hoppas folk som ska starta gym och alla andra har fått med sig lite tips.
Och jag hoppas att det här gymmet kommer att kicka äs och att vi snart slår ut de stora kedjorna om sådär 40-50 år bara att bygga upp en riksteckande kedja.
Ja, jag har inget mer att säga.
Nej, tack så mycket.
Han ser verkligen förstörd ut när han tittar ner i golvet.
Då var han sommarlagt och så ringer telefonen, det var ju trevligt och så bara hej, du måste ha bygglov.